this is gilat
baltistan here in Pakistani administered
Kashmir the planting season is short the
winters are long and cold the farmers
say they're increasingly on the mercy of
changing weather
patterns an is picking the last of his
tomato crop before winter sets in he's
one of the lucky ones benefiting from a
scheme offered by the United Nations
International fund for agriculture
development or IAD it offers money to
help local people to boost their
agricultural
output we used to plant our crops on
Open Fields with local seeds but now we
are using hybrid seed and basic
structure to support vertical farming
and making more money by using less than
half of the land most people here have
small land Holdings but are now making
bigger profits thanks to Vertical
farming not far away in the same Village
we meet gam Ali his children are helping
him pick tomatoes he says he got more
yield by using just one tenth of the
land it was difficult to make ants meat
with traditional farming but now I make
bigger profits with less
land this new way of farming offers a
promising future to people in the region
gilat baltistan is a region of rivers
mountains and Glaciers people here
depend on agriculture jobs but with less
than one % edable land and the use of
traditional methods Farmers here have
struggled to increase
productivity now more and more people
are changing age-old Traditions to reap
the benefits of vertical farming to
supplement their incomes and support
their families Kamal Hayer Al jaaz
skardu gilat
baltistan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer
click on the not